today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza
1811 pico boulevard in los angeles on
the way to the beach
gray block get that hitter
today's episode is brought to you by
magic mind
as well you know uh flow state
now comes in a bottle a lot of times uh
procrastination gets you
well change that coffee's not doing it
for you
change it up magic mind
dot co and use promo code theo for 10
off today's guest is
entrepreneur business owner
creator hard worker and
human mr jimmy john
leah
sit toad tell you my stories
you got started uh my mother's from uh
outside of peoria illinois but you got
started
in illinois and uh so take me through a
little bit of how
jimmy john's got started oh okay cool
so i graduated in uh in may or in june
of 1982 and it was about march and my
dad said to me he's like hey man
he said jimmy what are you going to be
doing after after uh
high school because you got to do
something you can't live at home
and he said you need to start applying
to college you got to start figuring out
what what you're going to do
and i college really was an option
uh i didn't do i graduated second last
on my high school class so
who was last you remember yeah craig
schumacher great guy
he was last yeah craig schumacher the
love master craig schumacher
oh yeah he was he was a classmate of
mine craig schumacher so
not the comedian no not the key not the
continuous shoemaker no
no okay different guy but uh yeah so i
grew so anyway long story short is my my
dad my dad was an entrepreneur and he
said look
you're not going to college uh you can't
live at home
you know you start a business you got to
do something so i said why i kind of
would like to open a chicago hot dog
stand i love a chicago
portillo hot dog and a tamale and a and
a french fry and and uh
i said i'd love to open a hot dog stand
he said i'll tell you what he says i'll
lend you 25 thousand bucks dang
and we're pretty good deal he says and
here's the deal he said
you get 25 grand if it makes it i own 48
if it fails you go to the army for two
years and you don't have to pay me back
he really wanted me to go to the army he
fought the korean war
my big brother greg drove a armored
person i'll carry my little brother
robbie was a
a ranger out in fort ord california so
you were
you're the odd duck total that duck
total odd duck
all three of those guys are fighters and
every time i got in a fight i just got
the [ __ ] beat out of me i mean
i don't know what to do in a fight i
just open up a concession stand that's
what you do
that's what you do you open up a a
sandwich shop so anyway
i graduate high school and i and
and so i go to visit hot dog stands and
and and in
two weeks i visited 50 i knew what i had
on them i need
i knew what i had to have on the menu i
knew what what equipment i needed to
have and
i made a list i made a menu list and my
equipment list
and it was easy i went to the library
and got yellow pages we didn't have
technology we would have google
and they had the yellow pages in the
library and i googled restaurant
equipment and then used restaurant
equipment
and i found places in chicago that had
it and i drove my car down to the city
and i found a section which is now the
west loop which is the hottest area in
chicago
but storefront after storefront of
entrepreneur owned little used
restaurant equipment houses right
so i had to list some equipment for my
hot dog stand
and the cheapest price i got was 43 000
bucks
so i drive back to home to carry
illinois and i say pop
he's yeah what's up i said i need more
dough he said what are you talking about
i said i need 43 grand just for the
equipment i got a fryer a steam table a
hood
i got a grill i got a flat top i got a
milkshake machine i got a he said hey
dude
it's 25 grand yeah and i'm like the bus
stops here huh
wow you're serious he's i'm serious as
[ __ ]
son he said so this is like mid-june
and so just it was random but i was
going to go visit a buddy at southern
illinois university
that next weekend salukis right is it
that is the salukis it is the salukis
so i drive down there and i'm partying
with my buddy he says let's go get a
sandwich
at boobie sandwiches i'm like what's a
little sandwich shop it's great
so i go to this little sandwich shop
theo literally it's got a refrigerator a
coca-cola refrigerator
there's vegetables in it there's meats
in it and there's beer in it and there's
soda in it it's like like coca-cola gave
it to him but he was using it all in the
same fridge
all in the same fridge he had a little
make table half the size your desk a
little refrigerator make table
a meat slicer and he was making and it
had bags of bread in a cash register the
guy's making sandwiches
so i just came from fryers and steam
tables milkshake machines
and all this [ __ ] all this equipment and
here i'm like there's a refrigerator i
said
i can do sandwiches wow so so just like
that so you went from
so before that it was hot dogs and you
just and that moment just changed it for
you that moment
changed my head i just came from 18 20
pieces of equipment for 45 000 bucks
i knew i could get a used refrigerator
for 400. i knew i could get a used make
line for
500. i knew i could get a refrigerator
for 250 bucks or a cash which is 250
bucks
i and and i knew i could get a new used
meat slicer for
six 700 bucks i just been through every
restaurant warehouse in chicago oh and i
bet
yeah especially in that area you're
gonna have it probably the best
opportunity because
so many restaurants in chicago have even
getting into that kind of stuff uh
here's a video question that came in
right here we'll go to one early that
came in for you john right here actually
yeah go ahead what's up this is a
question for both you theo
jimmy john you guys are two very
successful business owners
and i just want to know like what is it
that
motivates you the most that gave you
that drive that gave you that edge you
know
i'm looking forward to your answers uh
either way merry christmas happy
holidays both of you
gang gang jimmy jones thanks baby gang
gang and i'll tell you this
and i'll and i'll kind of add into what
i was going to ask and thank you for
that young man and uh
yeah because i was going to ask you so
to go from to switch from hot dogs to
sandwiches
so it wasn't really about the was it
still about the product as much or was
it about
because some people are like i'm selling
hammers that's it if you show them a
screwdriver they're not going to change
to that
so was it about business like did you
realize at that point like
oh i just want to do business or is it
just
food business like because that's kind
of a pivot i mean it's a you know
that was a real pivot but it was a
critical pivot but my homework was done
and when your homework is done the
answers were obvious i knew how much i
could buy used equipment for
i knew how complicated the hot dog stand
was
i knew how many items were going to be
on the menu and when i saw refrigerator
meat slicer cash register boom
three pieces of equipment man i knew
instantly that i could do that
especially with that fir when that third
one is the cash register you're like
okay yeah this all makes sense
absolutely because that other list
probably didn't have a register on it
and that's the one you need the most
absolutely so that's interesting so then
yes suddenly you're like oh this is a
paired down kind of
did it feel like okay this is a more
paired down version of what i want to do
or this is
no it was another option and so what i
did is i just pivoted and i went and
looked at other sandwich shops
um that were even at that time subway
wasn't baking in their own stores they
were getting bread delivered one or two
or three days a week so
so they weren't baking so i went and i
and i instead of just looking at hot
dogs hands around chicago
i went to milwaukee went to madison and
started looking at other sandwich shops
and i found a sandwich shop in in
milwaukee that baked their own buns and
this
and they and they they baked their own
bun and and and you bought your sandwich
on this homemade bun
and and they and you got a soda pop and
a 16 ounce returnable bottle when you
gave them the bottle back they gave you
your dime deposit bag
that was before your time right and but
the best thing about it was the bread
and and so i
after visiting enough sandwich shops i'm
like damn i gotta figure out how to bake
bread so i went right back to the
library
it's now july i'm right back to the
library and i got books on bacon bread
and baked bread in my mama's kitchen
and figure out how to bake bread and
then i had then i figured that out
so that was the next step so okay so
okay so you get to your bread
yeah and what are your parents doing
during this are they are they kind of
impressed i mean they must be impressed
with your
desire huh you know my parents were i
don't know that we were raised i think
we were
basically fed you know my dad was
working
my mom did i mean we got four kids and
we're all 13 months apart and there's
four of us three boys and a girl
so they we weren't really it wasn't
really you know
we didn't have sore any sort of
traditional raising
there's a lot of love in the house we
just didn't have there just there wasn't
a lot of time to nurture so
i was really on my own the feedback was
you know what's this guy doing you know
i think they were probably shaking their
heads and my dad was just hoping that i
would just
hang it up and go to the army i think
that's really what he was hoping was
going to happen
i mean like when i think about it right
now i think that's what he was thinking
about
but were you like uh so i got let me get
a little bit more what you're like then
were you like uh
because you weren't you weren't a dumb
you you did not well in your in your
grades and stuff but
you weren't a dumb kid no i wasn't a
dumb kid but i
i couldn't read and comprehend so it's
called dyslexia you've heard of this oh
yeah yeah one of my best friends has it
good so i just can't read and comprehend
so so even now married to leslie like if
if something comes in and
it's a letter somebody wrote it to us
even if leslie reads it to me i close my
eyes and i listen to it
and i can take it all in but i just
cannot read and comprehend so
i was sharp enough to do stuff i could i
was good at math
but i just yeah i just i couldn't read
man and and i think it pissed the
teachers off too and i think i think
they got angry because i thought they
they probably thought that i i should be
able to comprehend
and because i wasn't i must have been
you know
oh yeah screwing around yeah screwing
around and i wasn't i just couldn't
comprehend
you know it's like dance son well i
can't dance well then you're a [ __ ]
no i'm not i just can't dance
yeah yeah and then they think if you're
not dancing you're just loitering or
something else you're just doing
something uh yeah you're kind of ruining
the vibe then yeah yeah yeah so i was
but then what would happen then
i think teachers got a little angry they
would rib me a little bit and be angry
and be pissed at me
and i was sharp enough to be to stick it
right back to him and i think that's
probably what pissed the teachers off
and made him angry
because because i i i could see what
they were doing and i
i didn't know why they were angry at me
because there was no but when they were
ribbing me i would give it right back to
him i i was you know that's just
what i did were you funny in school were
you like a funny guy yeah i was funny
i'm i'm a
yeah yeah i had a good time that's cool
sure for sure were you goofy funny or
were you
talk like word funny like saying stuff
that was funny or would you like
were you like truffle shuffle funny kind
of guy or like just
say stuff no i don't know i think i was
i don't know what any of those things
mean really i don't know what truffle
shuffle were you like a goof or are you
like uh you would get up and do
something physical or were you just you
would
the way you more verbal it would yeah
like i could respond to [ __ ] quick i
could say it yeah yeah
okay yeah i mean i just you know i could
i could have a good time with stuff and
school is a fun environment
because you basically have kind of an
audience every day if the if the
curriculum doesn't really engage you
that much
yeah um which sometimes dyslexia to me
is just
that it's kind of like the like the
world of curriculum just it's not as
engaging for some people
and so your brain just doesn't leech on
to it so
it's almost like dyslexia sometimes can
be like a blessing it's like oh what am
i missing learning all this
[ __ ] that i don't really care about you
know yeah um yeah
so anyway so so we're at the bread so
you got the bread recipe
being from louisiana man i respect that
more than anything dude like
a po boy sandwich people are always like
what makes a i'm like you have to have
good bread like i don't care
other cities you have one in salt lake
city this is dog [ __ ] i want
you have to have good bread you gotta
have good bread new orleans has great
bread
great po-boys down there so gotta have
the great bread so i figured that out
yesterday
you got the great bread got the grape
now was there a day where you knew it
cause like i'm
i'm i've read michael lindell's book
you've read his book um he wrote the
he's the my pillow guy right
and he has a moment where he finally
gets the fluffing right in the pillow
and he just ca i mean he loses he's just
it's a great moment
right did you have that moment where
you're like this is the bread
i had a moment and i got a great story
about the moment so i got the moment i
got the bread i'm baking the bread the
bread's good
i'm going back and forth to the grocery
store and i lived in kerry and dominic's
grocery stores in crystal lake
and i'm going back and forth buying
meats and coming home and making
sandwiches on the bread
and i'm walking past the freezer section
one day and i see this frozen bread
dough in the freezer section had like
four like one pound loaves of bread this
big in a freezer bag
it was rich's frozen bread dough and i
grabbed a bag
and i threw it in the cart so remember i
had now i had my i had all my meats and
then i had this
frozen dough i take the dough home to
the house i thought one of these loaves
out and i cut it in quarters and stretch
it out
and bake it off into a loaf and i baked
the bread way better than the bread that
i came up with
okay and i looked at the bread bag it
said rich's frozen products
i think it was poughkeepsie new york and
at the time the entire new york the area
code was two one two
so i dialed two one two five five five
one two one two
and i said can i have the number of
richest frozen products poukeepsy new
york
and director assistant says sure one
moment please and gives me the number
so i call rich's frozen products and i
said hello may i speak to mr rich
the lady says one moment please no way i
swear to god
this guy gets on the phone and says
hello this is bob rich
i said hello mr rich he says yes ma'am
my voice said it was you know it's
pretty squeaky now but it's squeakier
then
yes ma'am what can i do for you i just
went with it i said
i said i'm opening a sandwich shop in
illinois and i said and i just tried
your
your bread donuts the way better than
the bread dough i made can you supply me
my bread dough he says you're opening a
sandwich shop in illinois he says give
me your phone number let me call you
back
so i hang up the phone and he calls me
back in five minutes he says you know
where schomburg illinois is i said yeah
i live in cary illinois
he said well my friend lou ganella is
building
an addition on his frozen dough factory
right by you
wow and i'm gonna and you go see him can
you be there tomorrow morning at 10
o'clock
and he'll he'll go set you go go see him
at 10 o'clock tomorrow morning
i said really he said absolutely here's
the address here's the phone number you
go tomorrow morning you go see my friend
lou ganela and how old are you
i'm 18 years old 18 years old dude
so i had a chevy citation man the
hatchback
i dropped was called a citation it was a
chevy citation man it was awesome front
wheels that's a ticket that's a parking
ticket
i could do better spin it backwards you
know i could do 360 donuts
it was killer yeah so i go so i go to uh
i go to this factory it's a construction
site
i walk in the front door and there's a
woman there a receptionist
and and there's two yellow hats there
and one says jimmy john on it
construction ads
and one says lou so i go and i go in
there
and uh uh i go in there excuse me ron
his name was ron
and he was it was lou's nephew or
something like that but lou owned it his
name was ron lucasy
it was ron and jimmy so one minute ron
comes out he says son put that hat on
but they come on with me
where you know i go into this kitchen
and here they got like
20 different breads all lined out fresh
out of the oven he says come on let's
play with some bread let's let's eat
some bread and see what you like and
and we'll make some bread dough and they
have mixers over here in
in about six hours between he and i and
i said i like this one pretty good he's
like
well then then we'll make that bread
dough for you i'm sure there's no way in
a million years did he ever ever think
that it would be what it was
sure enough i called him three months
later i said i got my location i'm going
to do it eastern illinois university
and uh son of a gun if i didn't end up
loyal
to that family and that company and we
are now their largest customer and
i think there's over a hundred ganella
family members that
that are owners of this company and
we're i think we're when we are their
largest customer now so
it was wow that was a it was an
incredible experience
and it was uh so random that i called
that phone number
and the dude was there was a bob rich
and he picked up the phone i mean what
if he was at lunch
yeah yeah and what and just the i mean
that just makes me think about like
when you do something hands-on for
somebody a lot of things in life it
takes somebody doing something hands-on
for you to really
believe that you can do it for sure so i
can't even imagine you walking in at
that age at that moment
you're already kind of a little bit
excited you're like here's adults
they're talking to me they know about
bread what's even going on i drive over
the hat's there with your name on it
like they went that extra step and i
wonder if they if
they couldn't be thinking this guy's a
big sandwich entrepreneur
dude i was 18 years old i didn't even
have hair under my arms yet man i was
yeah
late bloomer he called me ma'am yeah i
mean there's no clue
i'm sure you didn't know if you're going
to get hair under your arms if they're
calling you man
right that's right jury's out that's
right and and you know and my dad is
my my dad was thinking the same thing
but when i had this bread dough
and then i started making sandwiches on
that bread dough man i knew and i had
i came up with six it's now august came
up with six sandwiches invited my family
over they voted on four
and it was august and uh anyway it's so
kind though just the kindness that i
feel like they showed by
just saying okay here's just somebody
who's young and curious and i'm going to
extend some time to them you know
absolutely
i got to tell you a magical moment i met
a a grandson
of mr rich who has now passed away and i
i have a
i i spend the majority here in key largo
florida and i was in key largo florida i
met a grandson
of mr rich and i told him the story of
his grandfather the family also has a
home down in that area
and he was blown away he was blown away
it was so it brought me so it warmed my
heart
to share how that man literally without
that phone call in that moment
i wouldn't have pivoted there that which
would become the foundation of the jimmy
john's brand for you know 36 years
before
i sold it so it was it was an amazing
moment and i got lucky
i got lucky but it was it was in the
bull's-eye and i
i hit it and uh and so you got the bread
now
i really it's really interesting to hear
starting
uh uh especially like a sandwich shop
starting any business in a college town
i feel like it's such a strong move
because
if you can get a market that's excited
that's young
and it's something that's hip then you
know
already other towns it's going to work
in that exact type of place you know
yeah that's exactly right yeah when you
look back at that moment in your life
kind of at that young moment
um so some of the cards were kind of
laid out for you it was like you weren't
really college probably wasn't going to
be your thing right
your dad kind of gave you this amount
that didn't really work out with you
know with the
with the list that you made when you
lose fingers i go to the army
yeah yeah yeah he's looking for you he's
like jeez put the oven down and pick up
a [ __ ] gun
you know um but what was uh
when you look back at that one you're
like was it just some natural gifts that
god
do you just think it was just some
innate things like what are some things
that you know i really didn't think
about it i i really believe my dad i
mean my dad was a badass he was a
tough tough tough man he was he was
tough
and i knew that i was out of there and i
knew i had to figure it out so i really
didn't spend much time
about anything except i i wanted to get
a location i want to go to eastern
illinois university the reason i chose
easter my brother was coming out of the
army in november he was going
and i had two cousins that were there
mike and steve right so i said i'll go
to easter and i'm going to have family
there i'll open up the sandwich shop
i'll prove to the to the school that i'm
worth of [ __ ] and i'll get the sandwich
shop going and then i'll then i'll go to
college and get a degree and sell it and
go get a real job
wow so that was my plan and did you have
a lady in your life at this time what
was your
what was the love life like at this
point i didn't know what love was
really no i didn't i didn't have a lady
in my life at all no
okay not at all so not much not much
lady luck in the high school time no not
at all
okay so you get over to eastern illinois
you got the first sandwich shop
beautiful locale um is it still there
today
it's a it's right across the street it's
a tattoo shop now the original
i needed it was only 630 square feet it
was a it was a two-car garage
the there it was it was a house that was
converted into a dixie cream donut shop
had a two-car garage attached to it that
was a failed pizza joint i rented that
garage
for 200 bucks a month and there was a
bar behind me there was a bar to the
left of me and a bar in front of me
so i put my sandwich shop right in that
in that garage so
when the bars closed i came to jimmy
john so i chose that site
the rent was 200 bucks a month and i
anyway august when i when i went when i
was going to do it
when you know you said like what was
your family saying i got the bread i
figured it out i had my sandwiches
i drive down to eastern illinois and i
came back with two leases the garage and
i rented an apartment and i said pops
i gotta fund the account we're i'm doing
this and i it's i still really didn't
have much feedback from them at all and
then and they funded the account
and uh he gave me a checkbook and said
you pay for everything cod
so you live in reality you start with 25
grand
so i did so i bought i bought my
equipment i bought a used refrigerator i
bought a used meat slicer i bought a
sears chest freezer to hold my bread
dough
my mom gave me her oven mitts her
rubbermaid cake spatula
and she gave me her tupperware to keep
my tomatoes and
sweet and uh yeah man and i opened up in
this little tiny two-car garage at
eastern
at 19 years old i i opened up my 19th
birthday january
a day after i turned 19 january 13 1983
i opened up my first store so you knew
so so the 25 000 does come into play so
that money
at this point he's funding the account
so you have some money to help you go
absolutely yeah i had to remodel it i
had to build a counter i had to put
paneling up i had to i had to plumb my
sink and right
get my bathroom done so i did and i did
i spent 23
871 dollars i needed a thousand bucks
for inventory
and i remember the numbers and uh so
anyway yeah i opened up
january 1383 and i had a 1300 balance to
start with and uh
started out man that was it damn dude
and how many gary v
varner truck videos did you watch to
help start all this none i bet
i don't even know who that is it's it's
got gary vee it's like they sell this
entrepreneurial spirit to a lot of
people online a lot of times okay
it's not bad or anything it's just like
it's kind of the same thing as just like
get entrepreneur you know
like get entrepreneurial you know um
i wish i wish it was like you know one
of the kids asked he said
you know what is it what is it that
drives an entrepreneur what is it i
think it's fear
i think it's fear of failure i think
this was all driven by fear
you know that's really what drove it all
that's what you know
fear of the army fear of the army fear
of moving out
i had to keep the ball rolling i had to
get funded i think
i think really the fear of failure is
what really motivates
is the original motivator you know i
just i just didn't want to fail
right right and i failed my whole life
so i think that's that was a real
motivator
because what the hell else was i going
to do and i didn't want to go to the
army i mean there's no way i was going i
was going to get the [ __ ] beat out of me
in the army
yeah i mean it probably would have been
yeah it probably wouldn't have been
stoked especially if you don't want to
go
expect oh yeah that's you don't want to
be in there but you want to be the guy
in the army who doesn't want to be in
the army
right i think that's kind of the bad the
the tough vibe
you know you need stress relief that
goes beyond some quick fixes
and a quick fix is something that just
fixes you but it's is it good is it bad
who knows
it was probably made in china so you
need something more realistic and that
is
head space you know there's so many
things that is trying to get our
attention these days on our phones and
in the world and stop lights and
go lights that we don't have any space
in our head
headspace is your daily dose of
mindfulness in the form of
guided meditations in an easy to use app
you need some help falling asleep
headspace has wind down sessions
their members swear by that's right
you're settling down the kids are in bed
throwing some headspace relax
you can even tell your husband and wife
hey i'd love to chat but i need the
space headspace is backed by 25
published studies on its benefits
six hundred thousand five star reviews
and over 60 million
downloads you deserve to feel happier in
headspace is meditation made simple go
to headspace
dot com theo that's headspace.com
t-h-e-o for a free one-month trial
with access to headspace's full library
of meditations for every
situation this is the best deal offered
right now the best one
right now head to headspace.com
slash t-h-e-o i use headspace
and i thoroughly enjoy it the holidays
are upon us
but the season goes after christmas it's
not just one day
but the best deal in wireless can only
be found
at mint mobile right now when you switch
to mint mobile
and you buy any three month plan you get
another three months for free that's six
month of plan
mint mobile lets you safely order from
home and maximize your savings with
plans starting at just fifteen
dollars a month that's right just
fifteen dollars a month
mint mobile their best offer of the year
is here for a limited time
buy any three month plan get the extra
three months use your own phone with any
mobile plan so you don't have to change
phone you don't have to change number
keep your same number with all your
contacts if you're not a hundred percent
satisfied
mint mobile has you covered with their 7
day money back guarantee
for a limited time buy a three month
mint mobile plan and get three more
months free
by going to mint mobile.com slash
t-h-e-o
that's m-i-n-t m-o-b-i-l-e
dot com slash theo cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month
at mintmobile.com theo
um here's a question right here from
some young gentleman right here that we
got
what's up theo what's up jimmy john this
is mark coming at you from new jersey
as you can see my face kind of busted up
right now
got some of that caucasian abrasion from
slipping on some black ice earlier
my question is for mr jimmy what's it
like running a company with your name on
it
does it put extra pressure on you and
does it ever make it difficult for you
to separate your personal life from your
business
gang gang man that's a good question man
that's a really good question so
jimmy john is a character right and i'm
really jimmy leoto
and i'm and i know papa john really
really well papa john
loves being papa john he really does
he's very that's his sweet spot and he
just really loves it but
i'm done with jimmy john's i sold it i'm
jimmy leoteau
it was a 36-year career it was
extraordinary
i don't know if you've ever been
divorced before i have you know i love
my new wife is the love of my life
my ex-wife god bless her she's remarried
and she's doing terrific
but i i like my you know i really like
my my life
right i like i'm really jimmy that for
me it was a character
it's easy for me to separate but i think
it's different for different people so
that was a really really good question
um for me it's not hard but so so some
guys like being the character yeah
when did the character start to become
like yeah when do you start to become
the character like when does that happen
throughout this journey
you know what it it started to happen i
think that that you know wow you're
jimmy john
wow you're jimmy john like since it
wasn't top of mind for me
you know i was like this dude working my
ass off all the time
you know yeah and then i would forget
that i'm jimmy john because i'm working
my ass off all the time
oh yeah yeah that's right i'm i'm
totally jimmy john yeah
how is it oh it's awesome we get up at
five in the morning and we work until
three in the morning
seven days a week and we clean puke out
of toilets and we reinstall the urinals
on the wall and the dudes
tear them off the wall it's great you
know it's awesome being me
you know come on and be me for a while
it's the best
so i was always i was always taken aback
by it because i i really it was never
top of mind for me
i never like you know i never sort of we
you know we were we were we we i spent
10 years in 10 different cities
and and and opened 10 stores and that
was my first 10 years wow and i didn't
know how to do a bank loan or get a bank
loan so i'd save up my money
and replace myself at the sandwich shop
and then and then move to another city
and open up another store
and then in order to have the experience
be like it was when i was there
i learned way back at an early age to
cut my manager in on a piece of the
action right so then they have some
vested interest so then they got a
vested interest so so
you know i just uh i never you know so
like when did i start being jimmy john i
would say
probably 2 000 we started growing 2005
we had 200 stores
2010 we had 500 stores and and then when
it got to be really big
you know yeah i'm jimmy john but you
know it's not that sexy dude i mean we
got refrigerators and meat slicers and
and salamis i mean it's you know if
you're impressed by that that's fine but
it's nothing but a grind
right yeah at that point uh but at that
point probably you start to
make your way out of the actual store
that you're in and i'm sure it gets
you get into more of the corporate side
of stuff um but i want to i want to go
so
when you make the so you guys are things
are going well
things are going well you're right there
positioned by the by the bars
yeah um and you decide to do a second
shot
yeah um so does it feel like like was
that a risky move are you just
were you trusting your instincts at that
point were you trusting the numbers like
where did the where does it go come from
to take
that move so here's what happened theo
just simple so i opened up in january
with two of my buddies and me so there's
three of us
january february was great then one guy
quit so you have seven day shifts and
seven night shifts essentially
so then one dude quit so i took seven
days the other dude took seven nights
geez this is like the bible then then
march came and this and the night dude
quit and they i get a call at 4 30 in
the afternoon i'm in the sub shop
and and the dude says hey man um listen
i quit i said you quit
he said well i said why are you
questions because you're an [ __ ] wow
and i said
okay so what time are you going to be in
he says no no i'm out of here and the
customers came in and the phone rang and
one thing led to another it's two in the
morning so i got up and and and so i
closed the store two in the morning
after
and then then opened it up again at
eight and i and this is like
april of 83. so i'm working this
thing open to close eight in the morning
i didn't even know you could work from
eight in the morning until two in the
morning
if you have to if you ask the national
labor relations board they'll tell you
no
no way you gotta sue somebody for that
right yeah osha would have some issues
that's
right so but the first week i did it it
was really hard and i was freaking out
but the second week
man i'm like whoa i can do this and by
the third week theo
so i am starting to know my customers
who they are
what they like if they're chubby or like
me and give them a little extra mayo if
they were skinny like you i took a
little off
i used to use the ends of the meats that
weren't so pretty but they were still
salami and ham i'd sell those after one
o'clock in the morning
because nobody knew what they're eating
anyway so i figured out how to utilize
the waste and i really started getting
into
into into running the sandwich shop
after i after i
after everybody quit i just i survived i
just made it happen
then i learned i could work open to
close and then i started keeping
remember my dad said
keep your bank balance every day pay for
everything cod
and i'm watching this bank balance go up
and i'm watching it go up every day
and i finished the semester in may and i
started the semester with 1300 bucks
and had 18 000 bucks in the bank and i'm
like man i'm a millionaire yeah
and so i totally started paying
attention to this checkbook and so
the end of the first year i did 156 000
in sales and made 40 grand profit
i split it with my dad okay 48.52 right
and then the second year i did 180 000
and made 55 000 i split it with my dad
and i saved all my cash i got paid 200
bucks a week that's what my pay was and
i saved all the money less the tax
so i bought my dad out in may of 1985
for the 25 grand plus 10
interest so i had exactly 30 000 bucks
and i took it out of the bank in cash to
go pay him off
and own it he's like dude compound
interest i'm like what's compound
interest
he's like dude you owe me another 1300
bucks give me a break
so we got to 20 grand the first year 25
grand year two the original investment
bank then i owned it myself
then i worked another year and then i
moved then i replaced myself i moved to
macomb illinois western illinois
university
opened my second store 86 i moved to
university of illinois my third store
87 i moved to michigan state lansing
michigan and so that's
that's that's what i did okay so at that
point then you're on the go i'm on the
go you're on the go and
go back to the question where the guy
calls and says you're an [ __ ] were
you an [ __ ] i'm gonna
sometimes i i started out as just being
like fun and everything was fun
yeah and then once you get into business
man it's the adjustment sometimes is
really
tough yeah and i have to think with
another side of my brain and i have to
be a business person sometimes
and it goes totally against the whatever
the fun side of things
yeah were you an [ __ ] what made the
guy say that here's what i learned here
was the deal
no because i'm just not an [ __ ] as an
individual i'm i love people and i love
life
but what i didn't i didn't know what a
boss had to do i took the easiest shifts
for myself i took the easiest jobs for
myself
i sliced the easiest meats myself i
cleaned the easiest toilets myself
and gave everybody else all the tough
[ __ ] to do and so and then what i
learned
is that the boss takes the toughest
shifts the tardis jobs
sets his people up to succeed when they
fail it's the boss's fault
typically it's not the individual's
fault because people really want to do a
good job
all they need to know is why and you
just and if you catch them doing it
right
and the more often you catch people
doing things right and say man i really
appreciate the time you took
to clean that bathroom that way there
was not one hair left
anywhere in that bathroom you took the
time to do it you're a rock star
and if you are as a boss take the time
to thank somebody for that effort
they will say thank you sir and they
will do it again and i had to learn that
my guys quit i just didn't know how to
be a boss right then i learned how to be
a boss man
and then i read a couple of books on one
minute manager and leadership and the
one
manager and i learned that yeah i had to
lead by example that people do what i do
not what i say and so again it was out
of fear or survival i mean i had to do
it and i learned to do it then once i
realized i could do it i'm like man i
can do this
i mean i've never been successful with
anything in my life and i was killing it
so it was cool man now were you like
when you have the success so outside of
work in which i don't know how there's
any time
what what was your social life like like
did you start dating in college when
there's more women in college was
did you did you get a girlfriend did you
you know like what what were you doing
kind of for fun during that time
yes i use a freaking fun town bro yeah
charleston is a fun town
but i was working you know at first i
was having a lot of fun
and then and then i was working and then
i was really in the in the restaurant 24
7 365.
you know that's why how we made 40 grand
on 150 000
sales when your labor is 8 and i'm
getting paid 82 cents an hour
it's really easy to make that to have
that so i was really in the store
but yeah i dated a little bit and i had
a couple of girlfriends and and
and then and i had you know a bit of a
social life but nothing
nothing that where i could really i
always any time the sandwich shop called
anytime they needed anything i was there
i was there because i had worked so hard
to get it where i got it
that i you know i had a kind of a social
life but not a not not not
not a college social life but it was
fine yeah it was it was great you know
it was
it was it was whatever it was fine what
about like your first kiss let's just go
could we ask everybody this
oh my god do you remember mine i think i
i think and mine is the question we'll
saw i put mine out there too
is mine uh this girl i lost my virginity
behind a bowling alley everybody knows
that but
um my first one was this girl she had
kind of like a chipped tooth a little
bit named chrissy
and she had her mom used to cut her hair
like one of the singers from leonard
skinner like she would literally put a
picture up of
i don't even know who it was maybe i
don't even know who
and then she would have her sit next to
it and cut her hair just like it so she
literally
had it she had her hair looking just
like one of them
and uh some people just kind of we were
we were the same age in the neighborhood
we were both kind of shy
and uh they locked us in a room together
one time and
and we had to kiss you know and so we
did you know but
yeah my first girlfriend was peggy i
remember my first girlfriend was
peggy i forget her last name but i
remember that really really good
from college yeah cool check or no
yeah the time was you know was it was
what it was you know for me it was
awkward but it was what it was
where'd you guys meet at do you remember
uh yeah we met at the bars
oh yeah yeah what were good bars that
were uh i i
they used to have a comedy club no did
they have a comedy club there
we had rocks we had mothers we had ikes
and we had uh chinks uh where we'd go
there and do these slammer shots where
you'd get half whiskey half seven up and
they'd slam it
and you go to chinks and hit one of
those yeah and uh
oh god i would what marty's marty's we
had marty's
i don't the comedy club in charleston i
don't god i don't remember a comedy club
in charleston
i mean i really socializing wasn't a
huge top of mine for me
right it's just interesting to be that
young and to be
that like even when i when i think of
college hour if i think of just meeting
someone now who's 21
22 years old and they're that focused on
business
it and maybe it's just because of the
times now that would seem very
obtuse it would seem very unique
was it that unique at the time or did a
lot of young men that were just out of
high school when they started small
businesses
dude i i i don't think that i was
thinking about it the way you were
thinking about it man i was surviving
right buddy i was surviving i was paying
my rent
i was getting the money to the bank i
was getting the sandwiches delivered i
was figuring out how to deliver
figuring out how to how to buy an ad how
to how to make an advertisement
how to maximize my my dollars and the
advertising spend i'd save up my money
and
you know i said well if i'm gonna put an
ad in the newspaper i need to have a
headline and if i have a headline it'll
grab their attention
and so i would make up these poems and
so i would have a headline remember
everyone the headline was party
and said you plan it you love it you
can't wait till it starts it's dance and
romance then time to depart but alas you
just met a cutie that says your beauty
if that is your fate
it's never too late to impress that new
love with the jimmy john sub jimmy johns
we deliver
so it's a party all that fill in the
middle and then jimmy john's we deliver
and then and then and then i you know
and you just made these up
right yeah and when i did i did i did no
no zits no pits no dale bread
no grease no fries great subs instead
and i put these ads in the paper
but i had to think about this [ __ ] right
and i and i and i wanted it to be
somewhat adorable or somewhat like it
was worth it if you were going to read
it you could just smile
and and they all look the same so i had
to figure out because i had to save up
my money and buy an ad so
i was surviving i wasn't really sort of
like in a scene man
i was like surviving and figuring out
how to survive
yeah the ads it's very charming it's
charming the ads are very charming
you're a very charming guy have you
always had that have you just has it
always been a gift i think there's
something that's nice especially when
you're in high school to be able to
laugh but also engage with the teachers
there's a level of
of of uh intelligence that's behind it
but there's a level of charm that makes
it more
um palpable for everyone a lot of times
um
did you have you always thought that
that's a gift that you had being
charming dude i don't
i don't know that i really ever thought
i was gifted i mean
i was i was a fat kid and i was i was
raised in a
crazy household we went through two
bankruptcies
my dad was you know we ran out of milk
dude we drank powdered milk and i mean
we had love and
and we made it and my dad ended up being
a successful guy but
my childhood like i didn't have a
foundation i
i never really thought about you know
that i was a charming anything i just
just was you know i really never really
it was never in my head i just was doing
what i was doing so
i wasn't thinking about it you right you
weren't thinking about it but you had
some of you had survival instincts that
were helping you hell yes
was one of do you think just being a
charming guy well dude i
mean if it helped me out you know i mean
i can talk to people if it helped me out
i'll take it right
i can i can cook i can have a subject
and i can smile
and i can tell it like it is i don't
care yeah now what about the
like the striving to be good in business
do you feel like you were trying to like
impress your dad what do you think in
in the end sure yeah for sure i wanted
my dad's approval more than anything in
the world are you kidding me when i
think about
that man oh are you kidding me to have
your dad
approved oh man you know there's nothing
like it and uh you know my dad was hard
he he was a really tough tough tough
tough guy why is that man well i mean
yeah even me just thinking about it man
it kind of makes me a little bit
emotional but like yeah like
there's times where you do well in your
life and you think man uh
is your dad still alive no he passed uh
4 16
2016. yeah it said and it's like man
yeah
you're like man my dad would be proud
you know there's something there's some
innate thing and it's
for me i start to feel in the back of my
like shoulders your dad's still alive
you know my dad was 8 70 when i was born
when he when i was born he was an old
man
okay but so he passed away in uh 86.
but yeah there's sometimes a moment
where it's like
man yeah there's still this weird
connective tissue almost where i feel
like if i'm making proud that he can
feel it even though he's not here which
is really
i think that's what makes it the feeling
so unique yeah
yeah it's uh it's a it's a it's a deep
feeling it's and it's deep seated
especially if you had a connection with
your father
yeah and i had an amazing connection
with him and uh and he was a great man
and
and uh do you think he was proud of you
i think inside he was
i think inside he was like like i think
to to other people he was very proud of
me but
but to me he was hard on me and um
uh and it just was the way it was you
know it just was the way it was and
and my dad was old-fashioned and and he
was very macho
and he was very gregarious and outgoing
and and he probably thought a lot of
those things that you asked me
he was charming and he was witty and but
he believed you know with me i'm just
like i get like
okay you know but it's i you know but my
father totally believed he was
like he walked into the room he's like
yo i'm in the room and i walk in the
room like hey man
nice to see it theo you know whatever
just a little bit different
what are some fun things that did you
did your family through like a party
every year was it like a thing that your
dad like like what was uh fourth of july
man fourth of july we have a we have a
camp in northern wisconsin
yeah you told me uh uh bishop gun
performed there yeah bishop gunn played
two years in a row there and what a band
is bishop gone
oh my god you guys get your asses back
together man work it
out get it together travis no good man
unbelievable
dude they're so good so yeah but might
we would do a fourth of july and my dad
was in charge of the fireworks and man
my i remember the first year my dad in
charge of the fireworks
he got a couple of styrofoam uh
surfboards
and he and he put all like the the the
what are those balls that go up in the
air
those where they shoot the balls up they
go two and it shoots a ball oh why don't
you shoot up like ten of them
yeah it's not enough rocket yeah not
that well he had bottle rockets and and
and these other things where you can
hold the ball in there yes and the ball
would go up and then it'll blow up and
he wired and he wired all this stuff
together and i remember the first year
he did it he had these two
surfboards and he lit them both and and
he spent like two days before taping the
wicks together and making
doing that my dad was an engineer just
doing all this [ __ ] and he lit them both
and pushed him
and took them all both of them just blew
up and then
there was a total dodge show and then he
figured out those cannons
as and then and then they would get
those tubes you know with the three-inch
mortars and they figured out where to go
get them
i'm sure they were buying them illegally
in indiana or wherever i don't know why
i'm saying indeed
i remember something about indiana
illegal [ __ ] in indiana vote
and we will say that it's okay to say
that all right so anyway
but that was my dad's deal the fourth of
july party was great
and uh and i remember my dad would take
us to his company christmas party and it
was
the only thing fancy you know we it
would be fancy and we'd go to a company
christmas party
and it sounds like in hindsight like it
sounds like maybe when you
you were young and i'm not i'm not
trying to get in your life or anything
here i'm definitely fascinated but
i'm curious about stuff like you know
familiar relationships and how that kind
of plays into how we behave and stuff
yeah um because i wondered a lot about
it in my own life and i still figure
that out a lot i feel like i had a lot
of childhood trauma so i'm still kind of
figuring out
out sometimes but it sounds like you
know you're
that you were almost most like your
father in a lot of ways even though when
you were kid it seemed like your
brothers probably were
you know i i think that my brain was a
lot like my father but my father had a
natural confidence
uh that he just you know uh uh we were
just talking about bobby kidrock you
know bobby walks into a room and he just
he just he just owns it right yeah and
and and and um
my father was very much like that and
that bravado kind of
just bravado and just just owned it you
know and he can and i
i just don't have whatever i have i've
earned and i've
and i've earned and i and i pay and i
and it just doesn't come naturally
you know what i mean i've earned it i
work on it i because there's a lot of
insecurities being a fat kid being a
poor kid or
you know going through what we went
through there's a lot that comes with it
and i think it comes with you forever
and you get it
and then i think that i fought the
business so much and
the business went from you know being
the little sandwich maker guy
into this giant behemoth three billion
dollar company
and and so i i went from you know making
people smile and here's your sandwich
and thank you sir
can i sell you some chips to to you know
the evolution was it you know at the end
of the
at the end it was it was you know all i
can remember is litigation you know it's
just one
lawsuit after another right you're
freaking fast you must speed
uh no mister we don't speed well you but
you say freaky fast i know but we only
deliver
you it's a five minute drive time during
peak traffic and our and our
computer system won't take an order out
of our delivery area we don't speed
it's j we design the the delivery system
that way
well you but you you you but people
speed and you know
it was so hard to convince you know that
because we we got sued often for crashes
and [ __ ] right now oh really
absolutely well you're freaking fast but
then the people that we were freaky fast
not because we were freaky fast because
we i made the delivery area small
and i made the delivery area small so we
could be really have really good service
and i wanted to be the really good
service guy instead of the great
sandwich guy
you know and so i focused more on the
service than i did the speed
but it was but at the end you know the
it just changed a lot right
and that's why i just you know i just it
was uncle it was time for me to be out
of it
so but it changed a lot you know it was
really romantic at the beginning
you know there were long nights but big
problems i could solve and then it got
to
you know problems that i couldn't solve
then it just became a behemoth
it was a big big company when i sold and
we're vertically integrated right
we supplied all the food to all the
stores and oh wow so kind of like that
ray crock model kind of
kind of yeah yeah i think didn't they
yeah they ended up supplying
supplying all the stores a lot yes
applying all their majority of the
products we supplied so
yeah um now what point did you start to
study other business you know was there
a point where that were you like
we started to become okay i'm not a
sandwich maker
i am a businessman like does that kind
of start to
happen at some point yeah for sure no
for the first time is i'm learning how
to make sandwiches then i learned how to
be a boss and i learned how to do math
and i learned how to be an accountant
then i realized you know i got to sell
these things and i figured out how to
deliver
and then i figured out you know how to
uh how to print a menu and then i
figured out then i had to write a menu
and then then i had to
get the menus printed and then i said
you know what i'm going to take these
menus i'm going to print them on a
sticky card and people can
tear them off and stick them you know on
their dorm desk and so i had the
i had my menus they were sticky menus
and they were all over the campuses and
people loved stickers so i made my menus
into stickers and i saw my
my stuff all over the place right i mean
i had dorm rooms decorated with my jimmy
john's menus and i figured out how to do
that then i figured out
you know how to do an ad and i placed an
ad and didn't work and then i started
doing these big headlines
so i figured out how to place an ad and
then i figured out how to buy an ad
so then then i went through that then i
went then i had to find real estate then
i
had to figure out what is good real
estate and what works and what doesn't
work
and then i had to figure out what a
lease is and you figure out what a good
lease is by getting burned on a couple
of bad leases
then you figure out what a good lease is
and then you get good locations then you
get good leases and then
and then you gotta and and then from
there you know then i had to figure out
franchising i had 10 stores over 10
years and i
i wrote the opening and closing
procedures and i did that during those
10 years so
all of those 10 stores could be operated
the same way and my customers had the
same experience
whether i was there or not i compensated
my manager with a piece of the action
wow every time right every so that we
we're all copacetic all symbiotic
everybody's happy
so you had to figure all that out and
then as that grew then i then when i
and when i started franchising theo in
93 i joined this organization called
young presidents organization
and they said as a founder you gotta
give up your power
or give up and hire put a professional
in to run your company
cause you're an entrepreneur so i took
that advice and i hired some
professionals from
a large restaurant company to run my
franchise company
and dumb me stayed running the company
stores so in 93
i hired two execs and we started
franchising the jimmy john's mind
so i had to learn that i had to i just
save up the money to do it
and then i had to learn what a franchise
contract is what a
fdd is which is a federal disclosure
document that the feds make you
create i had to learn what that was then
when i had to write one then i had to
write a bad one to write a good one
so i figured out how to write a good fdd
you know and then and then and then to
figure out what a good franchise he was
and
so from 93 to 2003 we opened we had 176
jimmy john's franchise stores
and had 23 company stores and and this
is a relevant
part of this story my 23 stores at that
time
were making me about 4 million bucks a
year just those 23 stores
profit and i had no debt i didn't have
debt because i didn't know how to get
debt
and my sales were going straight up in
my 23 company stores
my 176 franchise stores sales were going
down and had 76 of them failing
so 93 to 2003 i was in denial i was
taking the franchise fees it was
intoxicating
yeah how much did you get now how much
do you get on the franchise 25 grand of
pop oh yeah
that was intoxicating money yeah and
finally james james north was my
president he came to me and he said
jimmy because we've got to stop selling
franchises man why he's just because we
got nothing these things we got we got
half the stores or failed and why was it
what's that what was the number one
cause of why the stores were failing
well we we so
we we stopped selling franchises but why
the answer the question is they weren't
following systems and procedures
and they didn't put our process on a
pedestal because the company
the people that i hired from this other
company didn't have such
systems and procedures that we had at
jimmy john's jimmy john's is the most
consistent chain that i mean jimmy
john's sba loan was the highest
performing lowest failure rate
sba loan in the country because we were
did you have you had consistent
experiences at jimmy john's i have
that's the re that's the reason for it
so they weren't following our program we
were
so we fired all those guys and james and
myself literally went on the road in
i had freddie was was uh
two years old lucy was three he's your
children my children
and here i'm going to go on the road
again now after i'm on the road 20 years
i'm going to go back on the road again
and turn around 76 sub shops that were
failing so he and i did we went on the
road
it was a 12-month plan we ended up on
the road for 18 months so we turned
around
70 of 76 stores ourselves with our own
hands
and from that point forward when we got
back 2004-ish
late 2004 i said i'm going to tell every
single person that wants to open to
jimmy john's that this is a lifestyle
this is nights this is weekends this is
no weddings no funerals
you can't get the sniffles you can't
have hurt feelings this is a brand that
if you buy into this it's like having
children man it's it's
it and i so i told people the truth
about it because i didn't want to do
that again i was done
i didn't i didn't have another one of
those in me and when you say another one
of those what do you mean like being on
the road for 18 months
24 7. did that ruin your marriage you
think no no way no [ __ ] no
i was i was i got divorced back in 93 so
i was i was with my current wife
okay and uh no it didn't ruin my
marriage but uh it made me because
that's a lot man
i mean when you say it it reminded me of
stand-up comedy like so many of my
friends funerals i've missed so many of
our
friends weddings i've missed yeah and
you you know it adjusts your friendship
when you don't make somebody's wedding
man it adjusts
your friendship with him a little bit
you know and it's kind of weird because
sometimes you get to the end of
some of the line and you have this
career that's nice but
you've definitely uh there were a lot of
stair steps that you missed along the
way a lot of social ones and emotional
ones with other people
for sure for sure but after we got back
from that and we did that road trip and
when we turned the stores around
literally you want to open jimmy john's
we told you the truth
we i was making enough money remember i
said my 23 stories okay so before you're
just kind of handing them out
yeah a little bit yeah but not anymore
so now what do you have to change in the
documentation on y'all's end to
assure that people will run it a certain
way is there anything legally that you
have to change
no but what i did is i had a
conversation like we're having theo
this is i'm jimmy your theo we're gonna
have a conversation about real stuff
and i i would sit down just like this
and say look it's nights it's weekends
it's
it's not forgiving it's not flexible
there are no days off do you really want
to do this
okay if you do it we'll give you one
store great you
we train you we made a really hard way
to come to champaign illinois
train for three weeks and do a two-week
internship somewhere else and a city
like their store is going to be made it
really hard for them to do
you know what i mean and then they did
that and then they opened up and we
helped them and then if they were really
good at it
we and they wanted to do another one we
let them and if they hated it we'd get
them out really quick
and so and so we teamed up with people
that really wanted to do it you know i
was in the selling business i was
hustling
so and then i realized well i'm hustling
but i'm hustling [ __ ]
you know and so i quit you know i
started just telling it like it is and i
remember i was in this beautiful
situation because i didn't have debt
i had i was making the dough for my
company-owned stores so i said if i'm
gonna have this growth vehicle
it's gonna be solid as a rock amen and
that's what i wanted man and you owe
that to mr northcutt a lot i mean
oh for sure absolutely that j that was
that was his idea to do that and uh
and jane he's he's brand president right
now working for inspired brands
was it har oh wow yeah was it hard for
him to stop
to like get your attention no because it
wasn't
no when he talked i listened and when i
talked he listened the greatest partner
in the world
he's a one he's one of the greatest guys
i've ever met i mean he's
trustee to my children i mean he's he's
a world-class man
meadowman met him in uh in in cold bay
alaska in 1999 he was a high school kid
and i just met him i said come on to
america and and uh i'll teach you to be
the greatest sandwich maker in the world
he said tell me about your sandwich up i
said it's great we're open from 10 to 2.
he says [ __ ]
i'm just i'm just out of college i'll
come where he opened to ten to two he
says i'll come
so he comes all the way from new zealand
to join me he says i didn't know you
meant ten to two a.m
he said i thought it was 2 p.m he's like
oh [ __ ] i'm here
anyway that's a true story so he's still
there and running up oh that's hilarious
yeah it's funny today's episode is
brought to you by better help
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional
therapist you can start communicating in
under 24 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is professional counseling
done securely online you know i remember
a couple of
uh probably about a year a year and a
half ago i pulled off the side of the
road
i said i need some dang help i was in my
car and i couldn't get any help so i
said i need better help
and i got on the phone the next scene on
facetiming
with a licensed therapist right there on
the side of the road people honking
people calling me the f word people
calling me dirty names creep [ __ ]
but i was getting help man betterhelp
was committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches
that make it easy and free to change
counselors if you need
visit betterhelp.com t-h-e-o that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
and join the over half a million people
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional special offer for this past
weekend listeners get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
theo look if you wanna if you want to
put that
you know an athlete is something that's
active something that's moving
something that is uh creating beauty
something that is making things um
that is in motion and what i'm talking
about is athletic
greens they basically took an athlete
and put it into greens baby one of the
ways i've taken ownership over my health
is with athletic greens
you take it in the morning it's easy you
mix it in it's a great mix you mix it
right in the water boom
i throw an ice cube in there for that
temperature of comfort
you get that temperature at the same
spot you needed at today's program is
brought to you by athletic greens the
most comprehensive daily
nutritional beverage it has everything
in it
75 vitamins and minerals do you know how
long it would take you
to take 75 vitamins
it could literally take you an hour and
a half they have whole food source
ingredients multivitamin multimineral
probiotic green superfood blend and more
they all work together to fill the
nutritional gaps in your diet increase
energy and focus
and aid in digestion yep go to
athleticgreens.com
and get a free one-year supply of
vitamin d and five free
travel packs when you use
athleticgreens.com theo join health
experts athletes and health conscious
go-getters around the world
again simply visit athleticgreens.com
t-h-e-o and get your free year supply of
vitamin d
and five free travel packs today
athletic greens.com theo um we have a
question right here that came in from a
young man
theo vaughn hello from england um before
i get onto my question for jimmy john
mr jimmy john i'd like to say to you
thank you
for you know your consistent rare light
shining through the dark times
um making these you know these uncertain
times a little bit easier to deal with
a little bit less of a struggle on a
daily basis so thank you for the
from the bottom of my heart for that and
to you mr jimmy john
um when i was over in boston working
over there
i got a taste for that uh freaky fast
freaky fresh hitter
um the vo and i was wondering when you
you plan on
bringing your sandwiches over to england
at all um mainly because at the moment
all we've got is subway
oh which sucks yeah and i made love to a
girl near a subway one school
show today jimmy john's freaky fast
freaky fresh international
is it a possibility um thanks guys
gang gang gang brother and thanks for
the nice words man merry christmas to
you man i love you and uh thanks for
being a a part of this podcast um
send me your address and i'll fedex you
some sandwiches anytime you want i'll
tell you what i'll do it for you once a
month
you just send you can get my my email
address from theo
and i'll hook you up i'll fedex them
with ice packs and you'll get them fresh
in england i don't own it anymore buddy
yeah we'll send you some though that's
that's very sweet of you that'd be great
hey look man it's a christmas gift for
you
from jimmy john himself man you know i t
you guys group does good though man
they set me up with a lifetime
membership oh really yep i i
i i've been a long time jimmy johnny i'm
a turkey time guy
and so i would get the turkey time and i
would just talk about it on snapchat or
on a
instagram story and then yeah one day
they wrote me back and
i remember i took the card to the guy
here and the guy was like dang i don't
even know i've ever even seen one of
these
he was like all stoked you know dude i
thought i was the only one that gave
those out so
good my guys were my guys were doing the
right thing i don't think they're giving
them to everybody though so
no they're not it was nice that they uh
that they did it though
you still got it i still got it yeah
yeah sweet i've
just we just shot a sketch this morning
with brett favre jr actually and we were
doing uh
we treated we uh gave the card to my
buddy to go treat everybody to lunch oh
nice i came over here
um okay so let's get into a little bit
more of like
so you got you have the business what
what changed for you when you became
were you guys rich when you were a kid
no i told you we were poor twice so but
we were bankrupt in 72 and 76
and i left home in 82 and then my father
i would say he started he got out of
debt in 76 and i when i was in high
school my father had a cadillac
so i don't know what your definition of
rich is or what your definition of spicy
is but he had a cadillac
you know and then when i left home and
and he became
way more successful after after i left
home you know what business did he get
into
so my father was a book salesman and
then he was a plastic molder my father
invented
the process of molding molten plastic
around metal it was called insert
molding
it was a technology that he he was the
he really created the technology and
essentially what it did is
anytime you could take metal out of a
part and and make the majority of the
part plastic
and just make the metal on metal contact
metal and the right you could remove
cost out of a part
so it you know it was a great technology
and so so
the first time he just didn't do his
books right and in 76 he developed a a
cb antenna and to make a cbn cb and a
lot of cb intentions you had to coil
copper wire around
a magnet and and and it was your antenna
base well my dad molded it and by
molding it
he could make him very consistent make
made him perform better and his top
salesman top accountant top
engineer uh split stole the design and
went and opened up a competing business
and bankrupted him
and that was in 76. and that's how he
got bankrupt
the second time they they and and the
government and the courts were so slow
that by the time he got to the courts
and got in suing him the antenna
technology had passed him
well the the cb business had been flying
and yeah basically
and so but anyway he learned and uh you
know had a little humility and and
uh and worked his ass off and and that's
that must have been heartbreaking though
you have your family going
you know you're working so hard on
something you're inventing you're
creating something
yeah it's like a baby it's like your
thing yeah
yeah and then somebody burns you like
that somebody burns you but welcome to
the club right
business man it's also business it's
life it's life
but from that my father created a
product called the k40cb antenna
that guaranteed it was guaranteed to
transmit further and receive clearer
than any other antenna
and he sold them uh over the telephone
to independent dealers
and uh and that became that became a
successful business and so
yeah dad dad ended up doing well but i
was gone i i mean like i told you i was
raised we didn't we didn't have stuff we
had a lot of love but not stuff
i think my younger brother and sister
had a little a little cushier time than
my older brother and i
um do you think your dad felt achieved
by the time he passed away in his life
my dad was very achieved
right do you think he felt it though i
understand that he was yeah i would say
was he content you know as content as
any man can be because contentment
you know contentment is fleeting it's
temporary right
perfection's a journey not a destination
right so you know i would say at moments
he felt but
my dad was pretty proud of himself um he
just was naturally
uh but to be able to fill that i bet to
be able to be it
yeah and then actually kind of stuff it
with the right cotton you know
by the end of the line i bet that
probably felt pretty cool yeah i would
yeah
yeah my my dad was proud of himself and
and and he should be yeah
he rocked it i mean he set the
foundation for me to do what i did
and i would listen to him when i was a
kid he was working all the time he's on
the phone all the time
and and and doing his books after he
after he didn't do his books right and
you know i learned to do my books
because i knew i had to know my books
and
i know one of the kids said you know
what do you got to do to be successful
you got to have a better product than
everybody else you got to know your cost
and you got to outwork the competition
and if you can do those three things you
can be successful but you've got to be
willing to do it you can't just google
it
you got to do it you got to get in there
and be uncomfortable when most people
don't want to be uncomfortable right
right that's how you did it so i don't
know where i'm going with that no it's a
good point look i mean
i remember walking out of uh you know
joe rogan's studio
and being like man that guy has it made
you know and
and um and then i remember thinking well
how could i do that and i started doing
some podcasting in my kitchen
you know and just kind of built it in
and built a camera and i would get one
of my
you know bought a camera and got a you
know just a thing on my desk and then
my computer would record also stay up
edit it put in the music and then one
day some people started listening you
know
putting it out there putting the product
out there and then a guy called me from
this place called grey block pizza it's
a small pizza place in
in la and bend oregon they have a branch
and they were our charter sponsor for
years and they still
are and really that's where the term get
that hitter came from which is uh
now one of our main merchandise pieces
but um
and he's still right now you're your guy
yep he's still my guy this uh this guy
thomas and he
said you know what man i believe in he
goes what you need to get you need to
get a studio you know you just
and he goes i'll give you a thousand
dollars a month and i said well man i
you know if you give me a thousand
dollars i'm gonna keep that thousand
dollars yeah i'm not spending on a
studio man you know i'm saying i'm gonna
take that thousand dollars i'm gonna go
retire
right now like that's where my brain was
and he goes no man you can't see it he
goes you can't see it but
if you get to here you're going to be
fine when you get there he goes
you've just never been there you know
you just nev and it wasn't a big jump
but it was yeah getting a place
and then we bought a studio man the
first studio we released was uh
take away this little enclave and it was
as big as this room and
man we had some amazing guests came in
there dustin poirier came in
jordan peterson who's one of the premier
like uh speakers and
and orders and and brains of our time
um bert christopher thompson just we had
amazing guests in this little bitty
space you know and uh was it in band
oregon
no this was in uh in l.a in l.a this was
in l.a yeah
but yeah we moved from our kitchen over
to another place and then now we have
two studios now we have two podcasts and
it
it's definitely it's a lot more work now
you know you don't get to just sit there
and be the fun guy sometimes you know
you don't get to be the you know some
friends of mine have been
in sitcoms and they say once you get in
the sitcom and it's about you
you don't get to be the guy telling the
jokes you're the guy in the middle that
everybody around you is telling the
jokes
and sometimes i think summer business
starts to get get to be like that
you don't get to be as much the the goof
anymore
100 of the time because you got to be
the glue a lot of the times you know
or try to be both you got to be both and
it's different things at different times
right sometimes you need to love
sometimes you need to
motivate and sometimes you need to
correct and sometimes you need to
celebrate and
it's a it's it's a balancing act man
it's spinning plates and i think we have
a very similar story
i think a very similar story just
different medium i was doing sandwiches
you're doing what you're doing
with your intellect and your comedy yeah
and uh you know yeah
it's a thing of self-serving it's like
how do i put out something that's good
how meticulous am i
were there times where you were too
meticulous because i find that in myself
sometimes i'm
too on top of people about things and it
almost just
it like debilitates me sometimes with
the folk where my focus is
sure that overall it hurts things you
know 100
use you know was i was i ever too
meticulous i was very much pennywise and
pound foolish
so when the business got to be you know
approaching three billion dollars in
sales
almost 3 000 stores 1900 in the pipeline
i mean this thing was a we were opening
30 stores a month selling 45 new deals a
month
i mean it it was a monster i wouldn't
even go to sleep if i was doing that it
was
i couldn't it was crazy it was driving
me nuts and when i actually talked to
james north today
who's the current brand president um and
uh
as i talked to him today he's a real
strategic big thinker
and i'm an operator like okay shit's bad
okay let's go get more drivers let's
bake better bread let's clean this door
better
you know let's uh let's let's make the
lights brighter you know i'm a real sort
of a pragmatic
operator and james was a real strategic
thinker so
i was focusing so much on on little
stuff
that i was missing sight of the big
stuff you follow me
and so that for me at the time that i
mean how i got it as big as i got it
i have no idea i got so lucky and
selling it and you know and and doing
the final deal in october of
19 you know before covet and everything
i got lucky
but but i was not ab i got way caught up
in the minutia
wait the lawsuits were personal for the
for for big companies lawsuits aren't
personal for me
it was another attack on me another
attack on me like the shark
another attack on jimmy another attack
on jimmy that's not me
i'm not that's not me with the shark oh
yeah that's jim no it's not me
right you know but the attack the attack
yeah that's you killing these drivers
whatever
that's not me man it's like we just have
a a advertising plan like
that's right wow so so so so i just so
when i when you take things personally
yeah
personally if you work real hard you
started from the grass roots it's all
personal to you it is personal it's
extremely personal man yeah so i'm just
getting over that now
and i'm actually when the when the sale
first went down
it was weird man you know because you
got sold for what 150
what do you guys sell for dollars 150
billion i was going to say 150 no you
know what that's insane amount isn't it
i'd love to tell you but i'm sure you
can't tell but it's confidence so you
guys
now when you sell then let's go to this
when you sell what does that mean you
sell
what are you still a chairman are you
still do they are you still
questions are you still doing sometimes
man
so let me let me tell you how it works
so you said like jimmy when did you
start to think about getting in under
other businesses you asked me that
earlier
in 2007 i sold 28 of the business
and so i had a chunk of dough and i
didn't know how to invest so i bought
farm ground and i bought gold
okay and let me tell you how naive i was
my brilliant jewish partners there are
awesome guys
michael lazarus he says he says oh you
bought gold what gold fund did you buy i
said what's a gold fund
he says you took physical possession of
gold i said yeah man i bought 400 ounce
bars and
he said he said you just buy a fun i
didn't know what a gold fund was
so but i understood farming you know you
buy the sea so so i started thinking
about other businesses and you know at
that time i
i sold 28 of it and then in 2006 then
i gave my employees seven percent of the
company
and i still own 65 in 2016
i sold 30 points of my 65 points
to a company called work capital and
they own
uh you know they they they have like
thirty thousand wrestling they own ant
dan's they own carvel
uh they have a com offshoot inspire
brands who we
merged with they have arby's buffalo
wild wings sonic and jimmy johnson now
just bought dunkin donuts right
oh wow so so i sold so i sold 30 points
to them in 2016.
and then 35 i merged my final 35
with inspire brands and so now i'm uh
i'm a large
shareholder of inspire brands and so
that's how it works and that's how it
works for me
it's not how everybody does it it's how
i did it and
and that that way just worked for me are
you pleased with how you did it looking
back yeah
are you kidding me i think i mean that
come on i mean are you kidding me well
but but when you're perfection when you
are someone who's
to the minutiae are there things that
are there things you would have done any
differently looking back
um because look man i'll be slaying in a
[ __ ]
gold coffin complaining about something
i got rid of the gold bars by the way
yeah i sold them at the right time too
oh thank god man yeah that's a tricky
business but uh um
you know are there things that i wished
i did different gosh yes
you know i i wish i i wouldn't have uh
there's a lot of things i wish i would
have done different but you know that
that's the beauty of life and that's
that's the beauty of age and wisdom and
and and with with wisdom and with
experience comes some peace and
and in my brain i got a side of my brain
that's been able to grow now
that that wasn't growing because of the
noise the noise was so intense and
and and the noise was just so intense i
mean my resting heart rate when i wake
up in the morning i was under 60 and i
weighed 275 pounds
you know and it was like a hundred you
know so it's
it's uh the noise is gone and the piece
is here
and and and my family's here and you
know life is good and my timing
i got lucky with my timing theo give me
a break yeah get out of here i got lucky
okay i'll take it
right i'll take it take it yeah
sometimes you put 100 bucks on red when
you spin the wheel and you hit red
i'll take the hunter take the [ __ ]
red yeah so there you go yeah that's a
good point
yeah sometimes there's even this weird
like thing about taking like luck you
know
it's like it feels like it wasn't like
yours but yeah it's like you got to take
that man that's life
it is like because it could just as
easily go the other way and it does yeah
and it most often does
absolutely it most often does let's take
a question right here from a young fella
right here
come on jimmy john one question what do
you get
at jimmy john's [ __ ] mind-blowing
oh you like subway better right on
so i love a turkey time with onions and
oil and vinegar
added to it i love a turkey tom that way
but if you get it that way you got to
eat it
immediately you can't wait my go-to
sandwich is the new east coast hoagie
so you got to get the new number seven
east coast spicy hoagie that is my
favorite one right now good for sure
i think it's the best sandwich that
we've ever we've ever done i like the
frenchie a lot but inspired brands got
rid of it did you have the little
frenchie nope i never had oh nope i
never had it never had i've always
gotten the turkey time except for
the last couple times i went i got a
club um
italians yeah italian nightclub yeah
number nine
so but i um i've been a turkey time guy
my whole life man i'm a real
i kind of stick with what works for me
you know uh
so you're 40. yeah i'm 40 now you know
now that i re i'm just sitting here
thinking jimmy john's just part of your
whole life oh yeah 100 jimmy john's only
of it was half of my life i i have a
hard time with the obvious i just
realized
you were grew up with it dude it's crazy
so if i'm touring or i'm in a different
city and
wherever i get the first thing on my way
into town i will
see if they have a jimmy john i'll just
have them bring one right to the hotel
so when i get there i have a jimmy
john's man
it's one thing that i do feel about
jimmy john's is
it is as reliable a food
that exists out there i every time it's
going to be the same and it always gets
there fast man
it's just there it's like it really is
it's just there the other [ __ ] i don't
know what's going to happen
people somebody might get shot on the
way deliver i have no idea but with
jimmy john's it's straight up
now i had i actually got i had got a i
hooked up with jared from subway's
sister a long time ago in the french
quarter this is a long time ago
so i've had some some unique
interactions with some you know with
some sandwich experiences over my life
but um
and then i used to talk about quiznos a
lot of times
now quiznos went under right yeah and
here's why i think and this just is a
straight mail you know
quiz knows i would go into quiznos right
and you get the toasted sandwiches
toasted right which i like
it's cool you know but the problem with
quiznos was there was just
men in there eating them so when you
have a toasted sandwich
and you're like bringing it up to your
mouth and it has like this kind of like
this big open mouth kind of vibe and
you're just sitting there there's other
men in there just looking at each other
it had this extremely homoerotic vibe
for me at quiznos
and i wouldn't bro and i think i really
believe that it hit a lot of them in
that way and it
it just it kind of made it too tough for
me to go get quiznos
and sometimes that it would burn my
mouth it would like
kind of chat me up a little bit and it
just felt kind of homoerotic
eating those in there because it was
only men in there i think they only
really cater to men
i i have no idea i never this first time
i ever heard this
oh this is a big theory out there but a
lot of women won't go get a toasted
sandwich it just
you know that's a good toasted sandwich
it's pot belly it's not dainty enough i
like potbelly they don't toast them too
hard right
i like that but um but anyway those are
some
sandwich experiences that i've had but
did you uh was there another sandwich
place you really enjoyed over the years
or
another business that you watched grow
over the years yeah i think that uh
let's what what businesses i
i think preta manche does a great job
i'm familiar with them
they're london-based mcdonald's owned
them and then they opened some stores
in new york they do a really good job
with sandwiches i think portillo's hot
dogs did a great job
i love to go throughout chicago right
yeah yeah yeah so my friend dick
portillo he sold about the same time
just about a year before i did
so another another great guy i love
portillos a lot
what else do i respect a lot um i
really respect chick-fil-a how can you
not respect chick-fil-a
i mean what they do i mean my pleasure's
getting a little old but i respect it
and that's what they do and it's what
they say i guess freaky fast could be
getting pretty old do
but um i think chick-fil-a has
incredible respect i think mcdonald's
new quarter pounder with cheese with the
fresh burger
i think it's an incredible product i've
had that yet yeah they're using a fresh
meat patty now really
it's really a big difference it's big
time yeah you ought to try it
how can you not respect in and out i
mean it's kind of a grilled cheese
sandwich flavored with vegetables and a
little bit of meat patty
but it's still pretty damn good and the
price is really really really good yeah
um what else do i really respect a lot
was there a good brand that came through
that didn't make it that you were like
man what happened here because this
thing was
that didn't make it kfc i do not i i
don't
i'm a popeyes guy you know but i love
popeye's new chicken sandwich
their chicken is just if they made a
heroin i would buy it
that's so good popeyes is good if
popeye's made a heroin
dude i don't think america would exist
anymore but yeah there
there's just something about their did
you ever meet that guy uh what was that
al copeland yeah yeah
and his son really what was that like
because i'll tell you this so
growing up in that area he put the big
christmas lights up by the edge of the
lake and
people would get pissed because they had
to drive their car by him and then like
people were like i'm getting old
i can't see the end of the bridge what
i'm trying so there was always he was
always this like flamboyant like uh
bigger than larger than life he was like
that was like my dad
but go ahead yeah he was just like that
he was like larger than life like
the big christmas lights and we're doing
this and we got a
you know you felt like he had a cigar in
his hand even if he didn't have it in
his hand you know
he was just larger than life he was he
was i used to watch his offshore power
boat racing remember he did that to the
cigarette boats he would
take hot girls back and forth from our
town over to new orleans
and then bring them back like a month
later a month later but i love that
stuff so much and i ended up creating a
or being part of an offshore powerboat
with the jimmy john's offshore part and
we won the world championship that way
and i that was all inspired by that dude
al copeland i thought it was so cool
i thought it was the coolest thing in
the world man it was uh
yeah he was a hero remember his
sunglasses and his gold chains
oh yeah big black hair oh yeah he was
killing it
he i ca i don't know if he was italian i
don't know what he was
copeland i'm not sure he wanted to be
italian yeah he wanted to be for sure
yeah he was a he was the legend around
our town around our area growing up
because he was just
he bought this big place right when he
got off the causeway bridge in new
orleans
and they had he put all of his boats in
his truck everything was big he put just
it was in these big glass windows you
could just see when you drove by for no
real reason
but just to be like hey this is what i
you know here's what's going on here's
my [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah um did you um
were there some what are some other big
entrepreneurial type guys i'm sure you
that's one thing that's probably
happened that maybe you didn't even
expect is like you probably got to cross
paths with some amazing entrepreneurs
over the years you know what i have and
you know i can't do a shout out to
somebody
so it's 1987 and my father knew this guy
named jamie coulter who's a pizza hut
operator out of wichita
and my dad asked him he and he met him
and my dad was in this ypo group i told
you about and my dad
asked jamie to visit with me and talk me
out of these dumb little sandwich shops
that i had i had three of them
at the time or four of them at the time
so i met jamie coulter
and jamie had 25 pizza at stores i met
him and at the time he made twice as
much money at his pizza huts than the
chain average
and we're talking together and he called
my dad and he said
big jim he says i'm sorry he said your
son believes in what he's doing here
and i'm going to champion him and
support him because he believes in it
and he can do it
so jamie coulter ended up building those
25 pizzas to 125 sold them
created lone star steakhouse created
sullivans
and then bought del frisco's and jamie's
been my been
been my mentor since 1987 and he's now
i just turned 80 years old and he is a
young 80
and he is he has coached me my entire
life he's taught me
he's taught me how to how to tie a tie
how to how to drink wine how to
how to how to talk to people how he he's
taught me about life he he he's
been a he was a he he was with me so
jamie i love you brother
and uh he's an awesome awesome dude and
uh he and i are partners in a new brand
uh that uh that's called seven brew out
of northwest arkansas so we have nine
little drive-through
uh coffee shops and uh and so he's my
partner in that so that's
that's a new venture that we're doing so
jamie coulter and then i have met
so many of the of the great
entrepreneurs um
in america i mean i don't you know dick
portillo from portillo's hot dogs and um
uh i mean i've i've i've met the coke
family and i
i met uh uh uh henry kravis from you
know the kkr and george roberts and
from those guys and james colter from
tpg
and and so many i mean it's endless how
many entrepreneurs
and then i and then i was fortunate
enough to to be nominated the horatio
algeria association you guys won it
right
i won it two years ago and just in that
and that alone i mean it was
it's me it's the ceo or the the warren
buffett's right-hand guy it's uh
roger penske's there peyton manning you
know it was just crazy company oprah
winfrey you know it's like
whatever how did a sandwich guy get here
like you know are you a magician
a magician they have maybe find it hard
to talk to some of those people in
certain circles or is it not really
yeah what do you find do you find
because like what are you gonna i don't
know what i would even say to you
let me tell you something yeah they are
so refreshed by refresh
people that don't have an agenda i'm not
i'm not i'm i'm not
beholden to anybody i don't have any
debt i don't owe anybody anything
i have everything i own is mine and and
i and i'm always help when i can be
helpful i'm not virtuous but i'm just
a just just jimmy and so when i talk to
somebody i think when you talk to them
real i think their guard goes down
and then i think they kind of want to
peel off and like hang with you and say
you know hey what's up
hanging out what's up you know what are
you doing what's new and i
they they are very endearing to me when
i meet
high-level people um they they're i seem
to
be able to just talk to them and i talk
just like this yeah and i don't think
that most people talk just straight up
like this right
and and i find that it's really really
easy to the
the more you are you the more they can
be them and and you they realize you
don't have an agenda and they just shine
yeah yeah and i think that's with any
human being not not wherever they
agree i think all human beings react to
authenticity and
genuineness and real man and that's all
people want it's a fair shake
yeah yeah there's something new about uh
i think especially in this day in this
age about vulnerability and how that
is becoming like a commodity
you know or just being able to relate
you know or hey i think vulnerability
just saying look this is kind of where
i'm at this is like some of my
things that are going on this is
something i can relate to you this is
some way
i think it's why podcasting has done so
well because there's just more of a
conversation
um like there were some like i like part
of me for a long time wish that bernie
sanders and donald trump would have been
on the same ticket
because i felt like they were such
opposites but it would be great to see
such opposites on the have to work
together
that is fascinating to then make a move
forward right
how about that and i've always thought
that maybe why does the vice president
just get to be the same like
let's pick the let's give an antithesis
so that there's some real
vitriol between the two heads before
they really make some choices but
um boy that is amazing that you what
what a way to think
that would have been a fascinating team
and you know what i think bernie and
president trump might have really
done a great job together i agree too
because i think trump had
an inability to kind of just he just he
was just a you know he's a great
business guy but his
i think he's just his his way of kind of
speaking to the everyday person i don't
know
i don't know and i don't want to get
into that but um
but talking to people that are when
you're authentic people dig it dude
people people dig when you're real and
they know if you're real you're not real
they know
yeah right people tell do if you really
care people know you care and if you
care
people will talk to you and they'll
respond as long as they're in a place of
of being
real too and you know and i think that
the people that are more present and
living in
are those are the people you want to
talk to any with those that are so
caught up in this world of
of electronics and all that as much as
they are the new you the word you told
me it's the new
fossil fuel yeah tech is the new fossil
fuel tech is the new that's
that that's my gem that i got from theo
today that is incredible so
you know but i think when people are are
living real they're they they respond
to real and i think that everybody at
different times in their life has
different
you know they're at different stages of
their life yeah you have to be not only
you have to be in
in front of something that's going to
affect you but you have to be open to
there's only that's the funny thing 100
people can tell me the same thing but
it's that one moment where it just gets
through whatever the
chasms are the way they're lined up and
where it really hits um
how did you meet your second wife how
that how did that come up leslie you
said her name was yeah leslie
so i was at mccormick place and there
was a and my buddies have a beef jerky
company called jack links beef jerky
and it's from up in northern wisconsin
where our camp is where bishop gunn
played right into minong wisconsin
so they were at mccormick place and i
had bulls tickets i was live in downtown
chicago
and michael jordan was playing this is
back in the back back in the late 90s
last time
the best dude every single game dude i
was
there really yes it went home home in
chicago yes for sure and you
you was your you weren't your brand
wasn't doing good then no you weren't
yo [ __ ] i had uh well i had like 17 or
stories late 90s i was i had all those
deposits oh i thought i was making money
out of my company stores i was i've been
i've had
i've been rich for a long time i thought
it was later than that i thought i
didn't know that your business aligned
uh your
some of your early success aligned with
uh when the bulls were still playing oh
yeah
well remember i had my company stores
and even though the franchise stores i
had 76 failing stores
i was still getting paid right because
they had to pay me a royalty right i
said look we're going to run out of fuel
we need to stop this truck and we need
to refuel it yeah so there were two
separate entities so my company stores
always made money but so anyway i'm at
mccormick place
to at a at a grocery store show and the
link boys
have their beef jerky booth and they're
hustling jerky
at their grocery store show and so and i
said and i had four bulls tickets so i
always kept two and sold two and it paid
for my tickets right
so my buddy jay says he's listen he said
we're going to bulls game he says i got
this girl that's working at wells blue
bunny ice cream booth right there around
the corner
i want to take her to the bulls game he
said you know can i said okay
let's go check it out so we walk over
there and this
red-headed girl is there and and with
this blond-headed girl that jay was
gonna take and
and they were friends and i said would
you like to go to the bulls game she
says yeah but you know just friends i
said for sure
a hundred percent just plans so we all
four go to the bulls game that night we
went to yeah i'm not starting at lovers
yeah
that's right we went to the bulls game
and at the united center they sold these
these bob chins my ties and you could
get an extra floater in there on the top
for an extra buck
so by the second one i was irresistible
and i got the hand on my knee and so
yeah
that was i was just irresistible
that's funny [ __ ] man sorry i got the
hand on my knee and we went to
gallagher's on the corner of racine
and uh racine and alt geld in chicago
to gallagher's and we went to the bar
after the bulls game and walking back to
my house we totally made out
and uh and then she came back the next
weekend for the restaurant show
which and and and she was doing the
wells blue bunny ice cream booth at the
at the restaurant show up and were you
at the did you have a booth at the
restaurant show or no
no no no not yet so i go so i
i took her i took her out friday night
and i said listen
it's ten o'clock i need you to take you
back to your hotel because i just can't
do this i
i you've got a a a boyfriend and and i
i just can't do this and i'm take you
back to your hotel so i drove her back
to her hotel
i called her at three o'clock in the
morning i said you up i can't sleep i
said i'm coming to get you
so i came together and that was that was
and then she moved to chicago a month
later
i asked her to move in with me she's
like dude i'm not moving in with you and
she had a
she had a a four-year-old son wow and
his name was spencer and she was 22 she
had him as
she was a freshman in college and had a
child so she got she got a job at the
time
how did she go to you know uh she went
to a southwest missouri state oh
you'll get a four-year-old there and you
got a four-year-old there
she got a four-year-old there and i was
lucky enough to adopt him so he's my
oldest son oh it's cool but anyway it
just all worked out man we got engaged
the following valentine's just leslie
and we've been through it all we've been
through
everything that a couple can go through
dude we've been through it we earned it
we love the [ __ ] out of each other
and and we're rolling you know we got
this thing so that's my story and my
love
dude that's awesome man so if you uh
after uh
let's go to this question real quick and
then i'll last one more and we'll finish
up what does this guy have here
thank you for calling brother hey yo hey
theo jimmy it's dave from louisville
i just wanted to hear you guys thoughts
on this tattoo i've had for about 10
years now
shout out to jimmy jones on the sub hand
gang gang
dude gang gang that rocks nice work i
guess that's a handy eats his subs with
that left-handed sub-eater i hope that's
the hand he eats the subway
yeah who knows what else he's doing man
uh that's beautiful man actually i feel
like they could have done the artwork a
little bit better if i'm really going to
be honest with them
but at the same time i totally respect
it man right i'm buddy
um have you seen a lot of people or
these that have done some weird things
like that for you or not and i'm not
saying you're weird brother but are
there people that have really shown up
with some tattoos and
buddy there i used to do a convention in
vegas every two years and
we'd have three four thousand people at
the in in vegas at a convention
and i and we i'd give away prizes and
rolexes and
recognize great performers and bring in
rock stars kid rock
would come players zach brown come play
bishop gun and come play and
and uh man i saw some i saw some big
jimmy john tattoos and some crazy places
and and i'm sure that they're sorry that
they put those jj's where they put them
because i saw some [ __ ] dude yeah i've
seen a lot
i've seen a lot anyway it is what it is
you've seen some stuff that's not on the
menu
i've seen some stuff that's not on the
menu for sure um all right let's take
one more here and then i'll hit you with
a question and we'll finish up
what's up theo what's up jimmy hey buddy
so my question for you is what's the
craziest customer experience
that you've ever had um i think mine
would be when i worked at jimmy john's
in downtown wilmington
um it was the first night me and my
manager you know working there till
three
four in the morning we got those bar
drunk people coming in and one guy
ordered and he comes back up and he goes
hey man i think some uh naked guy just
came in through the back and went
upstairs
and i'm like are you serious he's like
yeah and uh so i go get my manager and
next thing you know he goes upstairs and
he's bringing out some naked guy and i'm
like what is going on
subs are making people crazy hey man
free smells dog
right on um did you ever have any
wildness like that i'm sure you do right
there
and uh anything that stands out buddy
there there has been
so much wildness that i have seen 36
years on college campuses
with sub sandwiches buddy i've seen porn
on the internet done in jimmy john's
bathrooms
and that which has been nicely emailed
to me
uh i have seen i have seen
i have seen stuff i've seen i mean i
don't know
where to go with it it's it's
overwhelming uh
i think it's just human nature i don't
think it's jimmy john's i think that
you mix alcohol in late night and and
people i think that people just like
like as they turn into raccoons and they
start doing
you know they start crawling around yeah
they're doing weird [ __ ] oh you'll find
your [ __ ] cousin in the recycling bin
dude if you like
if there's enough drugs and booze around
yes sir um
what about uh what about so
in life you know you've i feel like for
me i noticed in my life there's like a
i found like an uh like i in the past
two years i've started to make a little
bit of money in my life and i never had
any money
yeah and money was always and i think in
a lot of people's lives
it's always it's a goal it's a motivator
it's a
and i don't know if it was my motivator
i think some type of a success was my
motivator and i've achieved some success
hell yeah but i felt like it's not as
there really isn't it's not as joyous as
you would
it doesn't pay off really exactly like
you've kind of
i for me it hasn't paid off exactly like
i felt like i felt like it was like
i thought it would yes it's not what you
thought it would be right let me tell
you so i'm 16 years i'm 56 you're 40
right yeah
so here's here's happiness is hard work
brother and it's it's hard to make it
it's five times harder to hold on to it
that's number one thing with money okay
number two money doesn't bring you
happiness you want to be happy
you got to watch your sugar you got to
drink a lot of water you got to exercise
in the morning
you got to keep your house in order keep
your life in order and you want to and
and i have to hang around people that i
aspire to be like
or want to be like because it rubs off
on me you got to have a presence of
discipline you got to have a presence of
balance
and and you got to have a little bit of
fun and you got to forgive yourself for
being human
when you over season your steak which we
happen to do once in a while as human
beings
and you can take that any way you want
to take it and forgive yourself so you
can get back on
the track of happiness and happiness is
hard work man
it is it is it is i'm a i'm a i'm
obviously a billionaire right
and uh uh but you know you can have
you can have 10 cars and and 10 boats
and 10 houses
and you can you can you can eat yourself
three chocolate cakes and six big macs
and six jimmy john subs
and you're gonna feel like [ __ ] yeah
okay and it's gonna be horrible and
you're gonna be a one
horrible rich [ __ ] okay and so
really happiness is hard work so and
genuine genuine happiness i mean real
not baloney [ __ ] you know right
being party that's fine but
real contentment happiness man it's hard
work and it takes work every single day
to do that and when you do it you know
when you do it every day or have a
presence of it
and then you have better weeks and then
you have better months and you have
better quarters and then you have better
years you know
i wish i would have known this 10 years
ago i'm learning this now
since i don't have all that the pressure
of jimmy john's so i'm learning this
stuff now and this is for me
i don't know what's for you but this
this is the wine i like to drink
i'm not going to tell you what kind of
wine you like to drink but this is you
know i had a wine class one time i paid
he says okay you're ready for the class
good wine is wine you like
great class over let's drink wow so i'm
like
thanks man yeah thank you what's all
that [ __ ] they're doing the rest of you
says that's all [ __ ] they're making
all that stuff
up because i felt so stupid with wine
right now i own a couple wineries and we
do very well
but that's beside the point so you know
it's just whatever it is to you but for
what i found is
you know i've been rich for a long time
and uh in my in my world
uh rich for a long time and and uh i
made my first million dollars in 93
and had no debt you know so and having
no debt is huge
huge i didn't know how to get it i
didn't know how to fill out the
paperwork well it's funny your dad said
that you know
yeah yeah and those bankruptcies scared
me and i was poor and i didn't ever want
to be poor again
and uh so i was a real saver and still
i'm very conservative i only invest in
things that i
totally understand you know or a person
that i totally understand i i really
tend to bet the jockey not the horse
interesting man yeah
so that's the list people the list is if
you want to uh
if you want to have happiness in your
life
i feel like you started off by making a
list of the things you needed in your
kitchen
and i feel like you kind of ended up by
giving us a list
of your experience of the things that we
need if we want to
you know have some sort of happiness you
know um is that your is that
do you feel like that's where your a lot
of your motivation is spent now kind of
these days like
finding uh just feeling good finding
some happiness 100
i think contentment theo i think that um
you know um private planes are
convenient but you can be miserable in a
private plane
you know all those all those perceived
you know kardashian amenities right or
whatever hollywood amenities all those
things are great but
but to feel good you got to feel good
and and it's hard work to feel good and
so
i'm filling in a lot of a lot of gaps
that i that i wasn't able to do because
i was fighting the battle for 36 years
and i was just overwhelmed at the end it
was just so big
and so i was i was like drinking through
a fire hose and now
you know really being addressed my
weight my health
and really every single day through this
thanks this this hunting season and
thanksgiving and christmas
and and really trying to balance myself
man i've done a better job this year
than i've ever done in my life like this
is this is my
the best life that i've ever lived and
i'm in a great direction and i think a
year from now
if we had a podcast i think you'll see
me 20 or 30 pounds lighter and
and um and it's just what i'm doing
right now and it feels good
yeah it feels good to sleep good it
feels good man
it feels really shitty when i drink a
bottle or two of tequila which i did
last week with uh
with bobby and uh and clint boyer we
went hunting deer in texas and we drank
a lot of tequila man and
and man i paid the price for three to
three days i mean hangovers at my age
are a week now it's almost not worth it
yeah oh hang over
your stock dip you know you know
um so anyway yeah man i just see you
know a little peace and contentment and
relationships with my kids and
and uh just moved to franklin tennessee
and in june and i love
it congratulations it's like old america
here it's uh
the neighbors we we we get to our house
we're at our house three days
the neighbors bring over a fire pit made
out of iron that a local guy welded and
and eight adirondacks chairs and a stack
of wood
and set it up and brought a cooler beer
and said welcome to the neighborhood
lit a fire i mean this where i live i
live in america man
this is america where people love each
other and help each other and
look after each other and that's how i
felt coming here to nashville
and and franklin and it's just it is
it's an awesome place
and uh yeah i'm gonna bring my whole um
bring everything down here and so yeah
where can we
we're definitely dipping our toe in it
for sure and seeing what that feels like
we wanted to kind of make this like a
have a different option
you know we had a mortician come on from
uh kentucky and he was like one of our
best guests ever
really oh he said look bro he said if
you kill somebody man kill him in like
kind of a rural area because
a lot of times it goes straight from the
policeman to the mortician
so there's not a lot of interior
detective work so if you can trick that
first policeman
into thinking oh this is a natural cause
dude it's straight to the mortician
and then it's straight to the ovens bro
you know that guy's making a different
kind of bread but
you know uh but anyway so just some of
the things we had a
female trucker on that was a really
amazing episode we're just trying to get
back into just like people that are hard
working people that uh
you know just capturing a strong bit of
a sense of america that's still left you
know
absolutely absolutely you believe that
entrepreneurial spirit and the the
american dream is still alive
you know what i do i think it is still
alive i think that um
i think that there were some unintended
consequences of some decisions that were
made
by some people that didn't run
businesses but made business decisions
and i i believe everybody deserves
happiness right but i think happiness is
hard work right
so when for example the minimum wage you
raise the minimum wage to 15 bucks okay
and then you and then you throw covet on
top of it every small mom-and-pop
business in america is done
and so they wanted to make sure that the
small guy could make a living wage at 15
bucks an hour their hearts were in the
right place
beautiful thank you you know so such
virtuous thinking but look who's got all
the money now jeff bezos got all the
money and
everyone and then every time one of
these little mom-and-pop shops is
selling
on amazon as soon as it reaches a
certain level amazon just knocks it off
and then there's something the mom and
shop pop shop is gone so it was the
minimum wage really
a good thing well the it was a good idea
but the function
wait till you see what happens after
kova theo so there there's some
there's some there's some you know i
think the entrepreneur spirit is alive
and i think that um that that it's going
to be there
always you know as long as everything is
fair we're playing with the same set of
rules
and elections are fair and it's real and
and that everybody you know
has to play with the same set of rules
as soon as there's two sets of rules
that's when there's going to be problems
so we need to get back to
you know we need to you know fences make
good neighbors we need we need to have
the same set of rules i think so
so i believe that um do you feel like
someone could that
what will happen to entrepreneurs after
we come out of covey do you think
there's going to be a good opportunity
for
um people that want to start something
absolutely i think should be huge
opportunities
here theo the opportunity is also in the
trades man
the electricians and plumbers and
construction workers and the real and
the pipe
these guys the opportunity in that stuff
is going to be astronomical it's because
things
no matter what things have got to get
built right so i think i think that the
wage in that stuff is going to be up up
north of 100 bucks an hour
so i think that's huge i think that that
that entrepreneurs that haven't got
their ass kicked really hard
and and and and aren't licking their
wounds they're going to be ready to go
you know i'm jumping back into this new
coffee business and i'm really excited
about it seven that's what it's called
seven brew seven brew keep he said
northwest arkansas they just started
yeah
so if you guys want to support a jimmy
john brand or it's inspire brands
uh or is it just well inspired brands is
jimmy john's seven brew is myself and
jamie coulter my mentor and a couple
buddies that's cool man that is cool so
yeah the entrepreneurship's alive
absolutely it's alive look what you're
doing look
i'm here dude i know look this is this
is amazing look it feels good
oh it's so funny all the the dream
guests that we've wanted over the years
we've had three of them and uh and
they've all happened now which is really
interesting
wow that's interesting but you're right
though and no it's just good to hear
from you because i feel like you've been
through it's just like you said you have
to get burned in a few leases to know if
the lease is good like you've been
through the burn leases to be able to
look at the rest of us and say hey guys
things you know it just
it hits us in the spirit like you can
still do this you know you can
so you can um jimmy john thank you so
much
man this is uh this has been awesome man
and um i appreciate you being here and
have to go do some fishing sometime or
something i'd love to do that it's
really a pleasure to be here and a real
honor
to be here my kids think you're a rock
star and you are you're a real humble
smart witty uh guy and i appreciate your
interest and and having me here i i
really do i did
i've never done this before so uh uh
thank you very much
you bet man and well when bishop gun
gets back together we'll go to one of
their shows let's do it
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling
like these leaves i must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel
but it's gonna take a little
time for me to set that parking brake
and let myself
i'll sit and tell you my story
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
pants
and these rails that i've been robbing
on there wants something that they're
damn they're gone